so welcome to the tutorial on developing
machine learning models as API services
this was born mostly out of my struggle
in trying to integrate machine learning
models into web applications so along
with a friend of mine here Mogens Matson
we built an startup called engine room
360 where we are trying to use machine
learning into a real-time shopping
application and and after that I went on
to work at you know do some projects at
insight and then at five starts where I
really got to understand tornado as a
web framework and then that's primarily
what I'll be using in these in the stock
here and then currently I am being
part-time work at MIT is where I help
teach mentor data science alright so
what's the problem
so problem is that we have a polygon
environment we have data scientists who
love in a Python hopefully and then
scikit-learn and and love to build
models from it but you have a web team
and web stack that might use Python that
might use Ruby or other languages so we
need to you need a way to make machine
learning models work with web
applications ok so that's the motivation
for this talk how do you make a machine
learning models production-ready how do
you make it work with their applications
and not out rewrite in a different
language so kay audience so here is what
I put down there as to you know you have
done some machine learning models you
have seen web apps you don't have to
have done any web apps for this
particular tutorial we have never
deployed the model okay and you're ready
for some hands-on tutorial all right so
that's the expectation so we will talk
through the architecture that I used and
I like how do you so we will walk
through pieces of it how do you build an
API service how will be how do we curry
the API service from a Jupiter notebook
and then we'll build a web app that
korie's the API service and finally we
will deploy this API service in d8
yes ec2 machine and then quarry through
our web app and we'll try to do all of
this in the next hour and a half so this
is the architecture that be that that
out that's a motivation for this talk
well you have clients you know coming to
your web application which could be Ruby
Python or whatever and then they have
ways to reach resources but there's no
easy way to read your machine learning
models machine learning models are are
not you know cannot be opened by other
applications they need to go up on dry
within the same ecosystem that was built
in ok and we got to make machine
learning model accessible to the web app
by wrapping it inside as a micro API
service ok and in this case we're gonna
use tornado as a web server for it and I
will later on I will tell you why
tornadoes that is a good choice for this
ok at any point if I have any questions
please stop me I don't want to talk
through these slides I want to make sure
that you know have any questions please
address them all the code all of this is
some github so we'll definitely you know
it everything is I put some notes on it
so don't you know don't feel it you know
you know it's the race you know to ask
me questions
alright so machine learning problems I'm
going to take a very simple machine
learning problem which is the famous
iris dataset that's integrated into
scikit-learn so so it's car it's a
classification problem you turn to
classify a given a petal and the sepal
length and width you're going to
classify what type of flower that is
okay so so you can see you know the
based on the various values you already
you have some good training data and
you're going to use to build a
prediction model for this you know for
this machine learning app ok it's a very
simple app very simple machine learning
model and it's in recent recruits a good
model here is because it's got a really
nice separation of data points so you
have all these by the petal length and
supple width you can actually see
separate these flowers very easily and
because you can separate them very well
I'm actually going to go with a KNN
model
very simple you know K nearest neighbors
model just trying to look at you know
who are the nearest neighbors to that
you know to each observation to identify
which class of flower to classify asks
okay so the reason machine learning
model is simple is because you won't
actually work on how do you deploy these
models alright so so it's time to
actually get hands-on okay so if you're
gonna build this machine learning model
as an API service you may not write any
code but you'll actually install like
you know pull down my git repo run it
locally and then we will walk through
the code what it does and then hopefully
then you can take it and apply to your
own machine learning problems okay so
that's the actually the location for the
Google slides you can pull that one as
well if at any point you feel like you
need to copy paste from the commands so
that's the Google slides that is yak
socks why eighty socks okay so you want
to run it through terminal so open a
terminal window and we actually going to
work with three terminal windows so we
would have multiple tabs on a terminal
ending eventually so right now we just
need one terminal window okay and you
know it's it's quite possible that you
know there are environments out here
that I have not you know tried this
before like I've tried it on one other
machine just before the stock so
suddenly going to be environment that
that's no no it's not going to work
under very nicely so I want to make sure
that people can work in groups help each
other out if you have done your step
please make sure that you can you know
you you do reach out to your neighbor
alright so this is what we're gonna do
the first step we're going to first
build this API as a service we're going
to build we're going to build this
tornado web server and wrap the
scikit-learn pickle the model and then
you're gonna predict from that model and
return that as a get and post API
service okay so prerequisite is you have
an account already installed on your
machine so you know almost everybody or
everybody has them don't be inside a
virtual environment because we will
actually create in virtual environment
the environment through this project so
don't run this inside a controversial
environment already all right so for
this project we're actually going to use
another project cookie cutter cookie
cutter is a very nice Python project
that allows us to you know pull in
templates and then use templates into
creating our own apps so if you can open
a terminal window you know not in a
virtual environment and if I can also
just create a new folder because we're
going to pulling two different projects
inside the folder so don't do it in
directly on the desktop just get a new
folder in your terminal window make sure
where you are because we will go back to
terminal window a few times and then do
pick install cookie cutter it's a very
small you know package it should install
really quickly and you should definitely
check it out the cookie cutter project
repo it's really nice one for creating
your own project templates when you want
to share with other people so that they
don't have to start from scratch alright
so if you have that the next one this is
where having the slides on your screen
is very useful because you can actually
copy and paste but you can suddenly come
in a type it in as well so you're going
to say cookie cutter instead of usually
what you do is get clone this git repo
but we're not cloning this repo we're
actually creating a template from the
repo so that you can actually build your
own projects from this repo so do cookie
cutter this URL it will ask you a series
of questions ok and it's only a couple
of questions actually it's only what is
the name of the project you want if you
have done django rails it's basically
the same thing you would say django is
start or something like that and then
it'll ask you you know what's the name
of the project you know where do you
want to store it and stuff like that the
same sort of questions but only two or
three questions and then that will
create the application for you I have
created default names for it so that we
all have the same folder names once it
creates it but if you feel like you
should change it feel free to change it
and the meantime I'm actually going to
go and do it myself as well just so that
you know I time it correctly clear let
me exit my terminals
all right okay
okay
what oh go into my temp folder pirate
arts tutorial okay
it's nothing in the folder I'm going to
do the same command copy this
all right so it's gonna already had it
installed so it's gone - you will not
have the question of yes and no so it's
going to create create the repo
hopefully the Internet is still working
should be asking
soft light
I'd like to this
all right
I have no idea
you know somehow my my Wi-Fi has gone
offline I can't get to my top bar and
this let's see again there was this one
I'm just gonna unplug just a second here
so that I can get to my smaller screen
they don't know why it's at Wi-Fi
offline I'm going to use that on my
phone
awesome I think I should be good now and
so
I'm just going to check make sure that I
have Wi-Fi on back awesome I have Wi-Fi
it's a tethered for my phone but should
be enough for this talk
all right so great
you go back here Ellis
so I'm running the cookie cutter and
it's going to ask me a series of
questions so it's going to ask me what's
the project name I want
I left a default name of I this API I'm
going to keep the default name you can
change it if you are using the template
to build a different machine learning
API okay
I'm going to leave the repo name as it
is you can put a name for yourself there
you go give a description
iris API service okay okay you can leave
it as an open-source license if you want
okay so once you do this you'll actually
see the iris API folder in there okay so
let's go back to the slide zero and then
the next step is to CD into the folder
change directory into the folder and
then we're going to create canta
environments and then install the
packages we need and then run the API
service we will actually run it and then
come back and look at the code because
so that everybody can catch up on the
environment and then we'll look at the
code afterwards okay so let me navigate
into the environment
iris you go I'm just going to clear the
screen just that it's back on the top
okay no now I am going to say python
python environment create environment so
i created it in create environment as a
python script so that it's works on all
the machines hopefully so should not
have problem with windows as well but
I'm not exactly sure yes yes so if you
don't have anaconda in one of the
earlier slides I linked to mini kondeh
so if you install mini conda then you
can do this but without mini condi you
can't do this because the environment
i'm crania canta environment you can
certainly do it with virtually no and
pip you can totally do this but i did
not write the script for it so you can
do you can look at my requirements
kondeh and then just to people install -
are that file name that should work also
no no it's not gonna bother me as long
as you can insert a virtual environment
always create a virtual environment yeah
in this case I'm using
canta environment but you can yeah you
can totally do it in virtual environment
as well it's because most of people
already had Conda installed so I kept it
as Conda environment but you can totally
do it outside of Conda environment and
virtual ames alright so once that is
installed it will tell you to activate
the environment I go back to my to my
code here so I have this way to activate
the nerman please make sure you activate
the environment before you run the
installation packages because otherwise
it's going to install on the you know
default Conda so activate the endowment
first if you're on Windows you mean have
to do just so sack windows I think you
are just activate env env I think there
is no source for Windows I think that's
the only difference
I'm not trying it but that's what I read
so I'm going to believe that I'm going
to clear my screen again so do this
after you do this you will see on the
top young V and V on the top left corner
which means you are inside a virtual
environment okay you're inside a virtual
environment alright so now I can do
Python and install packages i ns and
tap-tap-tap completion did you make
advantage of it these tips are also in
my slides I'm just copying the steps of
my slides into my terminal I'm doing it
in my terminal so that you can also see
and follow along okay and I would love
for people to follow along because one
of the struggles I had in building and
deploying apps is you know it sometimes
works for somebody else and then it's
hard to replicate it on your own
environments and your own machines so
I'm hoping at least for some of you
today
you can do it replicated locally alright
so once it's not actually done Oh cuz
kinda only in links the packages I
believe so it's nothing it doesn't
install anything new which is great ok
so once I clear it if you type Python
hopefully you will get this will get
Python 3 okay in fact everybody should
get Python 3 even if your default in -
python 2 is because Conda environment I
can create Python 3 and I meant from
even your Python 2 so everybody is on
Python 3 for this virtual environment ok
awesome
so after that is done there's only one
most have one more step one more step is
to build the model pickle because we're
going to pickle the model and then
you're gonna serve the pickled model
from our application from a server so
certainly one more step here so Python
you can copy this basically I'm open the
code just a second just to show all
these what this does it's it's going to
basically build a K KNN pickle for the
iris dataset that solid is doing there
okay and then it's going to put the
pickle in my models folder if I put in a
models for it's going to put this pickle
along with all the numpy array is in
this models folder that's really all
that is doing okay we look at the code
shortly okay after that I should be able
to do Python run by okay video python
under PI you should get this which means
that you are you know everything is you
know basically all your setup is
complete your application is running and
you should be able to go into your
localhost 9000 and it's ray APIs live
there is no fancy webpage because this
is an API service you're not trying to
build a web application here on this
piece of the project so just as APIs
life okay so I'm gonna pause here
actually because I think they have a
pulse set up here okay
yes yeah okay pause here come on make
sure everybody is on it okay I want to
pause here there's a slides again yeah
I'm just going to give it take a quick
to three minutes making sure everybody
is able to go to the install it be able
to see it
if you are not an environment where you
could see it then definitely pair with
somebody else so that you can even you
know watch over them and if you need any
help please lock me down this is a
tutorial talk so it's not a talk where
you know you know you know you can
totally flag me down and I can try to
come and help you or your neighbor can
help you
yes
yeah
in the meantime I'll just show you where
what you're headed towards I didn't ever
showed you a tree with this this is what
we're going to end up where we're going
to end up with the web app but you can
actually query and then it's going to
occur your API service and get you back
their predictions from your prediction
so this is a flask app that's going to
query our tornado API service that's
going to use scikit-learn to predict it
return the JSON response to flask and
flask is going to serve us back to the
page this is what we're going to end up
with but I want to make sure everybody
can follow through this tutorial so so
that's why money to make sure we don't
run through this
yeah if you have any questions please
stop me yes
how many how many have it running on
there locally okay
they have about 25% it's not really a
great sign but it's okay what yeah I
think once this step is done I think
others will be a lot easier because I
don't want to run through if you run out
of time we'll definitely go into other
steps but I want to make sure that we
don't lose people in the beginning and
if canta environment is a problem to you
you can directly do without the
environment so you can totally do this
without the environment you can try this
directly you can do fight on and install
packages start by without creating
virtual environment or without creating
the content vironment
step over there
145
I'm going to slightly move on from here
now and then we will try to catch up
with others in the next step so I'm
going to quarry this API from a Jupiter
notebook here I need for people who have
it already installed open a new terminal
window without killing this current
server that's running because if you
kill it then you can't query the server
so open a new terminal window new
terminal window and then in the new
terminal window you're going to navigate
the same folder that you created and
launched Jupiter notebook okay in fact
you need to activate the environment
again so let me show you what I'm
talking about here okay I'm going to
open a new terminal window okay
I would navigate to my folder okay temp
PI data tutorial I'm going to go to my
iris API I want to do source env env
okay so this will basically activate my
Kanda environment and if you don't do
this before you're going to put a
notebook it might complain that you
might have Python to 1 this is using
Python 3 so once you activate
so it's activate okay so it's activated
all right so the activate this then I
strike Jupiter notebook okay so Jupiter
notebook will open up this browser
window with the you know file structure
we will run through every file in this
just in a minute after we query this so
I go to the I'm going to go into the
Yamal source ml source folder and you
have a PI Python or bakkali API client
that I pre wrote for this tutorial
say API client it's got it imposed
because library and then we're going to
call you the local API server we just
launched we're gonna I'm gonna run this
you know and you can give it one you
know one you know one record or one
observation and it's going to come back
with the prediction predicted color or
the flower value for it and you can give
it an array of observe of Records and
it's going to give you back with the
array of responses
okay so if you have this up to this
point then you're actually very good
place then then you have it completely
configured and running on your local
machine okay so the steps were go back
to here you open a new terminal window
you navigate to the iris API folder you
activate the virtual environment that's
a stuff that's not listed here directly
but it's you activate the virtual
environment by doing this source
activate on Windows it's usually I think
just activate env and B and you don't
need to activate the environment let me
say also this you don't need to activate
environment if you are putting all of
this directly in your in your root Conda
you know you don't if you're not using
virtual environments you don't need this
activate step and then run Jupiter
notebook if you run your Jupiter
notebook then you should be able to you
should be able to run these three four
cells here yes
is anybody up to this point good I see a
few nods which is good and I'm going to
be here the whole weekend so if for some
reason in your machine it does not work
please feel free to stop me later as
well and then I'll help you I've used
Windows before so certainly can try to
stubble shirt it just takes some time so
the interest of time I'm going to move
on but but but yeah if you even if you
don't complete these steps you know
catch me after the talk or you know
today tomorrow and we will be set up for
you awesome all right so let's let's
walk through this code we actually ran
through a bunch of stuff we actually did
not see what it really does in the code
let's walk through this code before I
walk in walk through this code I want to
talk about what this web server does
there's one question on why tornado so
we're gonna address that question right
away okay so this is a slide I borrowed
from Jesse Jairus who is a tornado
contributor I really like how he
explained this slide so I'll try to do
some justice to it so he talks about you
know if you if you go to a piece of
place you know a customer walks to the
counter the person across the counter
takes your order and puts the PISA in
the oven and then the customer's leading
guess I was waiting for this piece have
to come back okay and what if the person
across the counter is also waiting for
the pay for the woman to cook it and the
new customer comes in you need a new you
know is it's a cane person on the ground
across the counter so for every new
person that comes in requesting apisa
here you need that many people to serve
it that many counters to save it okay
that's typically how a web server does
right there your process is blocked for
each request it's not able to do
multiple things at the same time okay
and and that's really you are the async
process in a turn of you know reverse
the it was the flow where where it turns
the i/o blocking is what is called
because you are waiting for external
resource in this case waiting for the
oven to cook the quick to pizza so so
the so the the person across the counter
comes back and takes an
next order while he's waiting for the
Pisa to be cooked for the first customer
okay the customer of course has to wait
because you can't go you know he can't
get his pizza for the next ten minutes
but but there's no reason why the people
behind him cannot be served at the same
time okay and that's and that's
typically what async async' pre
framework is in process does and tornado
is a async web framework in Python okay
and at a single thread out okay which
means we'll get to one one minute it's
non-blocking i/o concurrency so it's non
blocking with respect to IO so so if you
you know if you're going to make a
database call and we're making an
external prediction call external API
service call in fact you can make
multiple service calls and it does not
have to wait for them to return result
to serve the next request that's also
come to a server okay so it can do IO
concurrency ok non-blocking and that's
how you can serve thousands of requests
okay and the word single thread is is
basically it's it can concurrently only
work on one one job at a time right it
cannot you know work on all five
requests at the same time just like your
person across the counter he can only
take one order at a time but but he does
not have to wait for an external process
like this you know cooking through the
oven to complete for him to take the
next order okay so that's really what or
a tornado have a framework does for us
and it can process multiple requests and
you can suddenly have multiple processes
just like how you would do multiple
flask are multiple Django processes
running at the same time to serve these
multiple requests so that you're not
waiting being one request at a time and
I mean do okay here okay so what is it
what is it good for so it's great for
building restful api s-- although it's
actually full stack you can actually do
ginger templates you can pull complete
web applications in tornado okay but it
was primarily great for restful Web API
eyes which is getting post is what we
are going to do use this application for
so which means you can you can be a
great micro service you can make
services it's it useful when you have
slow database connections when you're
communicating with external resources I
need to handle large number of
connections I think we touched on all of
them so we talk or do you think I think
everybody talks about ok what
so that is async IO ok so this is having
a slide I borrowed from Anton Caracas
from his better asynchronous code talk
and you know Python last year so here's
the picture here which is async i/o is a
library I think that that's a really
main difference between in a where the
tornado as a web framework really comes
in place I think it doesn't lead to
complete asynchronous web application
just with async I you don't necessarily
have to do tornado with it but tornado
has been around for a long time he
despite on to and Python 3 compatible
and and they all do very similar thing
with respect to using some sort of a
polling mechanism so it once it sends
the request to the in our case since the
prediction request it can come back and
and and you know serve the next incoming
API request and then keep polling the
other requests when it is when the
resources available results are
available for us to to return back there
to continue the processing ok so if you
want to learn more about it so they go
into the talk and and I think it's also
posted online alright so let's go and
look at the code okay we not be looking
at the core at all
so let's look at the code here I'm going
to open a new window you don't have to
open it on your terminal I'm going to
open it here so we can see it together
here ok cv go over to temp or he else
okay awesome
ok so this is our complete application
environment ok you have a requirements
file and we have a run file which is
what we ran the run file has only two
lines which is going to run the server
ok
there's nothing additional in here I've
got nodes and documentation and how on
everything we're gonna do right inside
this app ok so you go to app folder in a
folder
it calls server main dot pi let's go to
server server possum so
this main dot pie so let me show you it
means Umar did a bit okay just to see so
in this main dot pie one of them you
know the primary job it does it's it
creates a tornado application kids
donate application and tell us what are
the URL endpoints in this case we have
two URL endpoints the first URL endpoint
is our index page which basically said
the app is live when we went to the
browser okay second URL endpoint is your
is a prediction API which is what / API
iris
slash predict is what we did okay and it
and it is going to call this iris
prediction handler okay we call it
handler I think other other frameworks
might call it controllers and then
what's neat about it of that is I can
actually pass in the model that it needs
for prediction
so I'm actually what I have here I have
created a dictionary okay here I've
created a dictionary and then I'm
loading all my models from the pickles
into this dictionary so the application
object has all the pickled models okay
and then it passes the pickled model
into this handler when it needs to serve
the request okay so it's using the
scikit-learn job live module to just
load the pickle the since you know same
way did dump the pickle okay and then I
want to show you the handler itself what
it does here and then we're going to
look at the model also quickly here okay
there you go so predict okay so you see
the predict function is being called
okay and in the predict function the
first few lines of code is just so that
it can handle not only single you know
single record requests but also an array
of requests so that you can respond back
with the array of responses in a dis
prediction it creates that a card and
then creates this e^x matrix okay for us
to query and then it's it's yielding
this blocking product so predict is a
blocking call so we got to make it
unblocking by running it inside or
inside a thread pool so we have we have
a thread pool
okay which in this case have D 410 in
the settings file so this thread pool
it's gonna run independently on the
thread and I'm gonna yield for that
result this is how tornado makes it I
owe concurrency so while it's waiting
for this predict function to return
result the IO loop can start accepting a
next request okay and this is really the
big difference between a flask app or a
tornado APIs because flask app is not
that much different in structure to this
tornado app because the next stop I am
gonna show you is a flask app okay it's
no difference but you cannot do this
yield for you no yield for a blocking
project in flask app okay you will
basically that that particular process
will be blocked and if for whatever
reason your call takes you know I'm
going to be having in an import time and
I'm going to have time dot sleep after T
seconds at 10 seconds there okay if it's
a flask app it's going to wait for 10
second it cannot accept any new request
that's the main difference there it's
not just both both both frameworks are
going to take the exact in seconds for
the primary request but in tornado it
doesn't you know it doesn't reject other
requests it's going to come to the
server it's going to also process the
next request that's going to come to the
server and that's a big difference or
primary difference between the async IO
processing that the tornado enables
through co-routines
and and the same same co-routine is is
the processor async IO module also just
a few things okay are there any
questions on this yes
no I don't think so okay again I'm not
sure if I'm qualified to say it's not
possible I have not found a way to do it
as I'd say because I have not done it I
don't know if it's possible I don't
believe it's possible because those are
blocking frameworks or NSA blocking the
way you have to create multiple
processes for handling multiple requests
so here the same process isn't able to
handle multiple requests yeah that's the
main difference between those two things
so of course you have thousands requests
coming to a Jango and flask app as well
but then you are handling it by putting
a load balancer and creating 100 flask
processes ready to accept requests but
there is a upper bound to the 100,000
right there's only only 100 requests at
a time you can process thousand requests
at a time you can process and the way
you solve that problem the way you solve
the problem in django and a flask app is
this you make sure that these ovens are
efficient they don't take ten minutes
they take thirty seconds so so you you
make sure you each each each process
does not take that much time but
sometimes you don't have control over
them if you're going to make an external
API call it can take you know two
minutes and and then and on the way to I
think I think I think the way deploying
and the way people manage that process
is having many workers many workers
being able to process and be available
to accept incoming requests but there is
always upper bound to how many workers
you're going to have because you want to
set it up but you can certainly Auto
scale and do other ways to manage that
and the difference in tornado is a
single worker it can be more efficient
right while he's waiting for the PSR to
be cooked there's no reason he has to be
idle right no business runs that way
right so there's no reason of a process
has to run that way too so so that's the
as a big idea and in the async process
and I believe other you know in other
languages nodejs or I think akka and
other frameworks - similar things okay
thanks for the question I think it's a
good one because alright let me go back
to the code here okay so so you see that
there is no callbacks here they are not
doing any callbacks
we're just yielding it which is you know
just Python yield from generator it's
just almost like a yielding from a
generator module that's really what
you're doing here okay
remove this code off just to make sure
and there's not as much code here
because there's no reason code has to be
here because it's just calling the
machine learning pickle to get me the
results there is no scikit-learn in a
module building inside here okay and I
want to show you one other file here is
you can browse through other files these
are not that interesting these are just
saying how many thread pools I want like
how many concurrent because I want to
process for that API I can certainly
bump it up because these are lightweight
threads I can have hundredths ah you
know as much process or memory I have
honestly in my machine I'm using a t2
micro a devilish instance for this
deployment and nobody's going to eat my
API second no I don't need thousand
threads on this okay and what else is in
here okay exception folder exception
file just as a listing of exceptions
I found a project that actually does
this very nicely where they have all the
exceptions in one place so I adopted it
here and then the base handler is one
place where we have this respond J so
this is what basically creates that JSON
response that's why when we go to our
Jupiter notebook you get the status code
as well as deed in a in a in a JSON
result there are lots of lots of
libraries that try to standardize how
you format your JSON results you can you
can even put a schema on top of it if
you wish but for this application it was
not necessary so I just have the status
and then the data that's was only two
properties that comes in the in the JSON
response and data is an array is because
you could actually have multi you can
pass in multiple
observations are multiple records and it
will return you back in the single good
question array of values okay
tornado can do lot more than this I can
can i in fact yield parallel yield
multiple futures in parallel it doesn't
have to do the you know so I'm in this
application I didn't have a need for it
so I don't have it okay
other than that there is no nothing else
this application honestly let me also
show you my build model code which we
just ran but we did walk through so this
is basically building this all the code
that is okay so I mean move quickly here
okay so here I'm loading the iris
dataset
I'm building a KA nearest neighbor cane
and model okay
and then I am pickling the model through
a job live I'm dumping the model into a
pickle file and on that pickle file
resides inside my common models folder
as a model dot pickle and then it cut
all the numpy arrays associated with it
okay and that's all this app is doing
and thats all your app should do also
because you are writing just a wrapper
service on top of your scikit-learn
model so all the hard work should be
inside your feature engineering your
pipelines all of the other places in
this here it should just load the pickle
run your model and then return the
result that's really all work should be
here and that's why tornado makes a
great framework to just do that layer of
wrapper on top of it alright how are you
doing in time good okay great I'm going
to slightly move on on this and please
feel free to stalk me afterwards as
question yes sure
yes
ya know good question yeah so it's again
you know they they it's like so the
question is what's the difference
between companies like y-hat our data or
other companies which offer model
deployment was just rolling it on your
own
I think the same difference between you
deploying it in a AWS ec2 was just using
hiroko to deploy things and manage
things right so you know in this
scenario you will have to you're
building a rolling up your own web app
as API service which means you are
responsible for logging it if you need
to scale it you know you're responsible
for scaling it but if your environment
already includes deploying your own web
instances right that is you you may or
may not have a need to use their
services but if there is a but they were
did but they are all great companies
right so and and you if the service get
you there faster cheaper you know you
should definitely do that yeah you know
this this is this is completely you can
do it on your own there's nothing magic
behind it to deploy your modulus what
this is trying to show you yeah that's
really all that is trying to show you
there is no magic in deploying the model
ready deployed very quickly very easily
but yeah but there may be instances
where they will do something better or
faster they can allow it you I'm sure
there are ways to do it but yeah cool
yes question
I I believe so I have not had a problem
of 10,000 requests per second to say
that but but if I go to every if I
listen to any tornado tutorial and he
talk the first thing they talk about is
they choose tornado because it is highly
scalable it can handle tens of thousands
of requests it's it's open source
Facebook project that they acquired from
friends feed and and the main reason
friends feed did this is because it can
handle thousands of requests
concurrently ok and tornadoes mean you
know I guess rise to claim fame is that
it is the only Python framework at least
at the time to do this multiple
thousands of requests per second it it
does not compete with Django with
respect to features and on all the
module plugins and all the other stuff
the only thing it competes on is the io
concurrency if you have you know
blocking are your database queries if
you have external API services then I'm
not sure if other frameworks will will
you know will be able to serve you that
well good question yeah yes yeah
question yes
can you use a microphone so yeah if you
wanted to mix and match to do so you had
like a applica web application which
needed a lot of data entry and retrieval
from tables so like list views and
things that Django gives you but you
also have machine learning would you
recommend using the two api's on
different like the two frameworks
there's different API s-- okay let me
address it by just you know saying
tornado doesn't do anything other than
just serve the request tornado does not
have anything with guru's machine
learning it's all done by scikit-learn
here tornado is a Python program if you
think of it that loads that you know
that basically loads like it learn model
as a pickle to file and then quarries
the model and returns the result and
then the same thing can be done by flask
you can be done by your Python script
you don't even need a framework for it
what tornado allows us to do in this
instance is a it's if you are prediction
query takes longer then it's it's not
going to it can accept a second incoming
request so it can it can do multiple
things in parallel when it's dependent
on an external service here the app
doesn't do anything the rapp app is
actually if you look at my app here or
angular it's a good question because
because that's the core of this talk so
thanks for asking that
so app actually doesn't do anything all
the app does the apps purpose is to run
the prediction query and return the
prediction results right that's really
all the app is doing which means the app
is dependent on this pickled
scikit-learn model okay with the pickle
scikit-learn model okay through our
infinite pipelines that we have inside
the model feature engineering that it
takes us let's say three seconds to do
one prediction it's a we I'm going to
simulate this year by saying import time
and time duck sleep okay time to have
sleep of three seconds for every query
okay then
other frameworks bill will not be able
to accept a second request fight by the
same process okay our thread okay first
tornado because of its non-blocking
nature of it it can it can basically
while it's waiting for the waiting for
the response from a psychic learn model
it can release the release the you know
IO loop to go and serve the next request
yes oh absolutely it's it's if you're in
fact if you go to the if you go in the
slides and go in the cookie cutter and
then if you actually go to my door that
will basically take you to the second
here okay here so if that will take you
to my kid have a handle and that's the
cookie cutter app for it and then if you
go in there that via its all inside
there yes III I don't know I don't know
Falcon I'm actually I'm going to move on
because honestly I don't want to talk
about tornado as much as this talk is
about just applying API services because
there's and secondly I like I'm I'm not
I'm not a tornado contributor so I don't
want to misstate some things awesome so
that so we walked through the we walk
through the code here says you know so
let's reiterate that you know build
model because the model and then our app
itself just serves the model that's all
it does okay let me move on to the next
step okay they're actually doing good on
time so we should be okay we have 30
more minutes at least
okay so let's add a web server that uses
this API service okay so here I marked
this third terminal because I'm
expecting that you have a terminal one
where your tornado app is running and
you have terminal two but Jupiter is
running if you need to if you want to
query from Jupiter if you don't have it
running it's okay okay and I in third
terminal I'm going
to create a verb app in this case I'm
using flask okay
the slashes are some framework to create
simple web apps okay so I'm gonna add
does this this cause this part of the
puzzle here so we already did what is in
the gray box what's in the gray box is
what we built and and and then launched
it on our local machines we're going to
do similar process to build and launch
this flask web app okay and if I run
through a little bit faster and then you
cannot follow up in your code please
feel free to stop me also but if you
have any questions please ask me those
questions okay so let's go on to the
next step so a similar process I'm going
to be a cookie cutter and then pull this
app so this time the only difference is
the last one is not called API it's
called an app so I'm going to copy that
okay escape okay we want to copy this
then go to my terminal and open a new
terminal which is this okay I'm going to
make sure I'm not inside the iris API
folder I need to be the top level then I
don't want to create this you know I
don't know claw create the city project
inside another project I want the top
level and then I do cookie cutter I just
make sure I have the right
zoomed in okay so it's going to ask me a
series of questions and I have the
default app name as iris app which
should be good okay I'm not going to I'm
gonna leave everything default and then
I'm going to let me show you what that
folder looks like so now the folder has
two projects in fact in there there is
an iris underst - API there's iris app
and I this API is what we launched just
you know a little while back which is
the tornado API server serving
scikit-learn model and then I this app
is a flask app which we are going to
launch now and that's going to talk to
our API server okay let me go into the
slides here and it's the same process I
have so UCD into the folder you create
the environment activate environment
install packages I'm really sorry if
people have trouble creating
environments
on on different machines you don't need
to create environments you can directly
install as well or if you want to we can
work together after the talk or later in
the evening or tomorrow and fix that
okay so I'm going to go into this IRS
app okay gonna CD into I this app and
I'm going to do Python environment
create environment just the same process
make sure your virtual number is not
active because we're going to create a
virtual environment for the web
application and the reason I'm being
specific about creating specific virtual
environments is is because when you
deploy these apps you you don't want to
you might have in a single web server
multiple apps running and if you don't
have virtual environments and boxing
each app then they may have conflicts in
the packages not immediately but
eventually okay let me activate it
source activate environment virtual
environment okay I'm going to clear my
screen to get to the top of screen okay
so next step is to run the packages or
install the packages and what is a
Python environment install packages okay
so this will basically install flask
primarily and then it's done actually
so it's installed flask and I'm using a
flask forms and that's ginger templates
and that's really it there is no nothing
else in there I want to clear my screen
again and I'm actually done with my web
application I'll show you the code also
Python run that pi okay now it's got a
flask running I go to my browser go to
my local host 5,000 in this case that's
where I launched my flask of default and
you will actually have let me zoom out
it's too much okay so you will actually
have this iris app in there let's query
it and then we'll look at the code okay
two three one five I don't know what
that is
this is Sentosa okay so i'm of the corey
yet i can quote it multiple times it's
going to come back and give me the same
result of course okay so you can change
the query so now our web app is talking
to the api server and we're gonna look
at the code right now make sure that's
what i had a mess
it's not running through any of that
okay so we had this did this did this I
did this all right
and then let's open the code yes awesome
okay oh I actually have the code already
open here great here so this is the API
I'm going to close these these ones so
that we are not looking at the wrong
server cool okay so this is the flask
app okay this is also a micro server my
microwave framework I like it a lot for
small projects and also big so again
this is just going to run run the
application and an application it's
importing from here it's getting a flask
object and and then it's setting a basic
logging module config which you should
use and here if I go to my view start by
is where the routing is it's got two
things in here
one is the form that reduces to should
give you the give the top-level form and
second one is it validates the form and
then gets these four flower values that
you entered and then it uses the query
iris API query is API and then gets the
result and returns back the form that's
really all it's doing and when I go to
my query iris API it's actually using
requests module Python request module to
make a call to our URL with this JSON
payload and you would be familiar with
this from I want to show you this one
this this is exactly the same code that
we wrote in Jupiter notebook okay so you
are creating a payload which is
basically all the features that you need
for your model or at least in this model
and then you're making a post request
with that URL endpoint and giving the
JSON payload that is the same code
that's here just a little bit of extra
you know the error checking to make sure
that we are getting a response code
correctly okay and in my config dot pi I
am telling it where my server as the API
servers located
in the when we read the flask module we
did not very not instrument in a run the
build model dot pi there is no model
here it does not even know scikit-learn
in fact scikit-learn is not even
installed here it's not even part of the
requirements okay this is a complete web
app okay and and this could be you are a
totally non pythonic web app as well it
could be Ruby or any other web app okay
using the same sort of API service to
talk to your mission Learning API
service are there any questions at this
my yes
yeah totally I could have but I want to
show that you could access from any
other web application so I want to just
show that you could access this API from
a non tornado application you don't need
to it doesn't have to be a tornado and I
want people to walk away feeling that oh
this is all tornado ecosystem I want to
just people walk away saying that this
is a micro service that I that let me
back up
also in saying yeah yeah and also I want
to back up and say that you could have
done this in flask as well you could run
this in Django as well but you could do
the same process of wrapping your
psychic learn model into a flask app
into django app that totally works
right I'm just showing you how I have
done that in the past and why I like it
to be the good fit for this kind of a
simple service that does not have any
templating in fact it does are full you
know it is full fully featured but you
don't need to if you are if you are data
sign you're a scientist I guess or some
sort of a machine learning engineer
while you're just building models and
you are trying to all you want to do is
to make this model accessible to other
ecosystem within your enterprise then
you know that that's really all this app
is trying to do there and and then here
as an example
I have created an apps just so that we
can we can demonstrate that process the
interent process of it is good question
yeah
awesome great customs cool alright I
need that costume
great we are actually doing good on time
okay let's deploy this on AWS okay for
this step I'm not gonna have you follow
well you know follow along with me I'm
going to do this deployment here I have
it all documented in the notes section
inside the github as well so if you want
to do it yourself afterwards I highly
encourage it do it and then catch me
doing the conference outside and if you
have any issues but I want to show you
how easy it is okay so I'm going to easy
too much ec2 you know my account I guess
okay so I created an image just so that
I do not install mini canta on it that's
all that's why I have this image okay
and then I launched from this image so
from this mini kannada image and if I
did not if I had more time I could I
would have created from scratch okay
which you could also do if you you know
what let me show you that and then I'll
come back to this okay I mean go to
instances I'm going to launch an
instance and then I'm going to let me
zoom out a little bit just quickly here
okay I won't choose a boon to 1404 you
can certainly choose any sort of a Linux
flavor that you like
okay Linux we went to 1404 okay I won't
use a t2 micro okay we just got a 1gb
ram which is more than sufficient
because it is not memory bound or doing
anything in a complex over here okay and
then you go the next step you choose how
many instance you want and then you go
and launch it into us okay that's the
process so I'm going to use my a mine
here just because I have a couple of
packages installed on it and that makes
it process macoco quicker okay it's the
same t2 micro okay I'm gonna go here I
want only one instance
okay 8gb is more than enough I'm gonna
say iris API pie data
service okay next I'm going to choose an
existing what all I need to do is to
open up port 80 okay
you should do SSL which is 443 but you
could do SSL through load balancer of
AWS as well you don't need to it through
I'm going to choose 80 and 22 and I'm
going to launch my instance so I choose
my key path that I already have creative
PI data launch the instance okay so once
this is launched okay let's go back here
once this is launched it's it's got
nothing other than two steps I'll show
you what two steps it is here deploy
here these are the only steps that's
already been done these exact five steps
on top of a bad bones machine so I
updated the instance I installed the
gate on it I installed mini Condor on it
because I don't need a full anaconda for
for what I'm trying to do in this
project and then I you know basically
added it to my bash profile or - I see
okay that's all has been done we're
gonna do rest of these steps we gonna do
rest of these steps to basically install
the app deploy the app and serve it on
the web okay so we should be able to do
it in ten minutes okay let me go back
here and it's actually initializing so
if in the meantime if you have any
questions because we are almost towards
the end of the slides itself which is
good because you want to run it and
demonstrate it here
so we have IP address let's go and login
he open a new terminal okay or the ssh
using my PEM key for pi data
okay it may still be initializing so
it's not ready for me to login it may
not have the still initializing okay and
I want to leave it here just to see
other it's up done great okay so it's
got nothing else on it so I'm going to
walk through my deployment steps to make
sure I got it right okay no deployment
steps and then just do it okay so I'm
going to clone the repo now this is the
practice my so if I let me show you what
this repo really contains just
so I'll go back to my repos here this is
the repo
so this repos the is is the iris API
that we just build and walk through okay
it's got the same folders API client
build model it's got a folder which
contains the tornado app okay so let's
go here and I put them because I'm here
I'm just gonna copy is on here we get
clone okay it's going to clone this repo
great clear the screen at the top okay
great
so now I CD into this this this these
steps are exactly the same steps that we
walk through when installing it locally
I'm going to create the environment
Python environment create environment
just going to create a virtual
environment are canta environment for me
to use great then I'm going to activate
it source activate okay done I'm going
to install packages Python exact ops
Python environment install okay it's the
same steps okay it's going to install
all the packages this might take a
little bit of time okay so once this is
installed all what we're going to do
next is this I'll just show you that
while it's installing okay
what we're going to do next is we're
going to put the process the Python
process inside a supervisor supervisor
is a process manager so supervisor can
actually manage multiple process it can
auto restart the process it can
distribute you can keep multiple process
running it can you know you can also log
our processes so it's a it's a great way
to run your Python applications so
that's what we're gonna do next and once
we run it in supervisor our app is
actually live at that point okay
once this is installed time good
awesome stun so let's go and then the
next step is to actually install
supervisor lets me install
let me first run the program just to
make sure it's running it's not going to
run actually I need to I need to build
my model if I run it you will see it it
says the models file doesn't exist
because I didn't build my model let me
run it and they build my model Python
see build my model which is going to
pickle and build my model now I should
be able to run my application great but
this is not how I want to run it I'm
going to cancel it okay I want to run it
as inside supervisor so that it can
manage and then you know start my
processes so I'm going to run sudo
apt-get install supervisor okay so it's
a process manager you can process you
can manage multiple processors through
it okay so now I want to add a
supervisor conflict and go here so in
this is about the difference between
Ubuntu as a center yes as well
your conflict files might be so you have
to be careful if you're using a
different version of Linux and not to
Boone to version two you know put your
files in okay so I put the same I'm
going to go to insert mode I'm going to
basically copy this and we'll talk about
it paste this awesome
so all I'm trying to say here is I'm
calling the Python inside my virtual
environment that's what that is okay in
a home
iris API I'm calling the run dot pi okay
I'm making sure debug is false because
it's running as API service and then I'm
setting it to port 80 and that's how
it's going to serve on HTTP port I'm
setting the port to 80 okay and running
only one process you can run multiple
processes if you want okay and that's it
I'm setting the value the log file
should be standard error standard out
and you can set a Python environment
variable here okay and then I save this
right quit and then I just need to set
my supervisor reload which basically
reloads the conflict and I can monitor
my state
of my running processes so it's run
starting great brain okay running great
awesome so now it's running so you can
take our IP address that we just created
in ec2 let's first test it in Jupiter
notebook make sure that Jupiter can't
see it I'm going to just replays the
localhost with the IP address so let's
just said that is actually that's it
gets the result from the IP address so
it's actually going to the a SS machine
whirring it I can also go to the aid of
this machine directly here and you will
see out this live okay that's all it is
you can't use the browser for coding the
API there and then one more thing we
want to do is also use change it in a
flask app let me go into my flask app
you may config I go and remove the
localhost in a flask app which could be
hosted anywhere and then I change it to
this API save this okay and then it is
in debug mode is actually running but I
can also cancel it and then rerun the
flask app and go back to my browser and
then I can give this and then it's
actually going to get the results and
that results is coming from our API
server not from our local host because
that's the conflict users API server
there so you can suddenly DNS it to your
own domain names and stuff like that or
you can do other things and then there's
only one more slide here and then we'll
take more questions yes
my flask is running as open or localhost
but my the tornados running aw server so
so my tornado is not running here I can
even cancel it right there's no tornado
running here this is also only the
Jupiter notebook that I can kill it if
you want and then this is the flask app
flask will still of course get it right
so flask is running locally
I have not deployed the flask app I only
duplex a good question actually because
I can definitely be a as a confusion on
this the way I have represented it so
flask is running locally but the API
tornado is deployed yes good yeah thank
you thanks for the question yeah great
yeah so one more slide on this actually
which is this one awesome so so what we
did is what is on the right side box
your supervisor process and you pulled
put tornado processes inside to
supervisor process that for the most
part is enough to serve it over HTTP
okay particularly as a micro service
okay because you're not serving static
files you're not serving anything that
needs to be cached okay but if you want
you put a load balancer on front of it
like engine acts okay or even a SS node
balance that if you want you can totally
do that right it's that's something I
have not shown because I didn't have a
need to do it in my own projects as well
but you could also do it but if you do
with flask app or any other app you you
must need that because you have to serve
flask app through G unique on a u.s. key
and then that means to be served through
engine acts you could not have done just
through the process that we did that
easily so I believe to be okay that's
really all I had I think we did good on
time I think yeah so so many questions
please feel free to ask me and then yeah
if you don't add anything to what has
been said also please feel free to talk
you